well i remember
uh it being described to me that you
said because he was gonna knock so that
was the bit
the as a tribute to evil knievel he was
gonna try to recreate
the double backflip which at that point
had been pulled by nobody but
you travis pastrana right like in
competition you're the only one to do a
double backflip
so knoxville says i'm gonna do the same
thing i'm gonna do the double back flip
and uh they said that you told him
that's great
go for it but whatever you do just don't
let go of the bike
because if you let go of the bike it's
gonna it's it's gonna
leave you in a vertical fashion
which means it's to come back down and
land on you and that's what you don't
want so
so make sure you hold on to the bike and
knock some goes flying up the [ __ ]
first thing it doesn't
let go of the fly's the bike in the air
and it comes right back down on the land
the bike landed on his deck and broke
his urethra and he had a [ __ ]
catheter tube down his dick for
for [ __ ] dude i think he kept that as
a badge of honor
for way longer than he needed it dude
knoxville's the only one i i don't even
think not that it was that long ago but
i don't think he'd get away with this
today and i know
nobody else on the face of the earth
could ever get away with what he did
we're on a southwest flight
um four rows in front of him and he had
a catheter that made it that far and
i'm sound asleep my mouth wide open up
there he puts the catheter
over top of my shoulder everyone's
giggling
he like literally goes back four rows
people he doesn't know
and they're like oh that's knoxville
this is gonna be great and he pisses on
me
in a plane from four rows back
regular commercials southwest flight i
wake up
everybody's laughing i'm thinking how
did he get away with this
and and i was pissed on so at 30 000
feet
good times but only knoxville dude he's
got that that the way about him
yeah he does have that way about him he
can get away with stuff
and he had the bag strapped around his
ankle he called it his lemonade stand
wait how long did he have this cat dude
he kept that thing for [ __ ]
years man five years years
it happened and when did that happen
2008
yeah yeah i know he had it for at least
a year and a half and i i'm i'm with you
i don't know i think he just like the
pranks he could pull with it
yeah dude